I am thrilled to have you here on the
podcast that's a strong word
I am thrilled oh I'm gonna say that
because a number of reasons uh always
admired you and think you're uh
incredibly cool but we also became
friendly you I know you and your man me
and my lady I love I'm in it for the
wife that's the only reason I'm friends
with you exactly yeah what you're saying
Sona uh my favorite thing about Conan is
Eliza yeah by the way I I remember
talking to someone
unless it's like 10 years ago now and
they were like you know I liked you when
I met you and then I met your husband
and I liked you more and I thought I
think that's a compliment I'm not I
think I don't know if it is but it made
me feel confident that I chose well you
chose very well right like he can hang
out he's nice he's are you kidding he's
a delight he's really smart cool uh and
and we've hung out a bunch of times in
situations where we're on vacation we
bump into each other yeah and let's just
say a skiing kind of place yes uh and
um you're with your family I'm with my
family and we end up hanging out and I
remember very clearly you inviting us
over for charades yeah uh one night and
running charades you were running it
yeah no it's called Running charades the
game is not just simple charades it's
running charades like you have teams in
different parts of the house okay all
right to run to get your Clues and then
go give them that's right we were all in
separate parts of this house and you was
divided us into teams and then we had to
run and there'd be I don't know what
you'd call this person the wizard or
yeah whoever the game master the game
The Giver The Giver The Giver was on
these back stairs and you say what the
clue is and then you'd have to run back
to your team and here's what I learned
that night you're one of the most
competitive people I've ever met in my
life Elizabeth Banks is terrifying
you're a terrifying person truly no one
who actually knows me would disagree
with that statement
and what's great is that you were really
determined to win and I kept thinking
this is fun but then you'd win and you'd
be like in your face
we won
I don't I you're not wrong that I don't
I'm not a I'm not a gentle winner where
does that come from because we have some
things in common we both come from
Massachusetts obviously I'm 70 years
older than you but uh you you come from
Pittsfield Mass yes and uh you know
large Irish Catholic Family that's right
I come from Brookline Mass one of the
things we've bonded over yeah over time
yeah so how did you turn out Cooler Than
Me
you you actually are you are yeah you
kind of kill them well you know so half
my family is also gingers
and so that's another thing I like about
you you remind me of home and all the
best things
but I didn't get depressing I didn't get
the ginger so I think that's part of it
like I didn't have to grow up worrying
uh daily about like being made fun of
you
oh
I know like that's not allowed anymore
right can't do it keep kind in mind at
all times that's the whole thing yeah
yeah that's what we're trying I think
making fun of people's gonna come back
and gonna come back strong and I'll be
ready for campaign you wanted to come
back but yeah didn't people make fun of
you why would you say that yeah maybe
you were awkwardly tall had really long
legs you were like 40 pounds yeah uh yes
I was mocked uh and abused uh but in the
best ways I'm just I just I mean I had a
I had a great bully like a really good
bully she was excellent
she was good at her job of the bully
thing she and frankly like what a great
she's a professional bully pretty much
so I had to walk like I know this is
very tropey but I did walk through the
woods over rivers the whole thing to go
to school and after school those woods
became like the bully zone you know like
if you were walking home afterwards and
you didn't want to smoke cigarettes with
the guys who went out and they're like
dirt bikes you just got bullied by them
so I don't understand bullies in the
woods is a whole different thing I
remembered encountering bullies over
near
Steven's market at the point uh not too
far from around pakis one of the packies
exactly and and but but what I I'm just
imagining walking through beautiful
Woods yes in in this nice part of
Massachusetts this rural part of
Massachusetts and then you just a bully
steps out behind a tree that's literally
what it was like
literally was like
but the great news is
that I stood up to my bully
in like fifth or sixth grade must have
been six I was because I was in Middle
School North Middle School that's all we
had it's north south you went to I lived
off of North Street this is North Middle
School and um I came she was pushing her
friends into me in the line you know in
the lineup to go back in from lunch or
we never recess I don't think in sixth
grade maybe anyway and
um I and I I finally I just had it and I
turned around and I pushed her back and
she fell to the ground in front of
everyone
and it was super embarrassing for her
and I was like I'm a superhero
never felt like the adrenaline of like
the whole thing and like I've defeated
my boat you know and the best part was I
happened to be chewing gum
which is not allowed and so I didn't get
in trouble for pushing the ground no one
saw because there was like a whole group
that like circled around us you know at
the moment and then someone one of her
friends like pulled her up but everyone
was just in shock that I fought back
yeah and then um and so I turned around
like
doing my gum with my adrenaline running
yeah and the like monitor at the door
was like yeah Elizabeth
gum and was like you have detention and
the worst thing at that moment I could
get was detention because the bullies
all got detention and so then you had to
walk home the 30 minutes later there was
no one in the woods to save you if you
were alone in the woods I had to go with
the pack yeah so I literally I remember
I went to the the detention person I
don't know and it was like I can't stay
after school like I'm being bullied by
this person I can't say their name
because I don't want to get them trouble
because I'm not an arc and but
stitches exactly all he was doing was
doing gum can I do it like I'll do extra
homework like anything but I cannot walk
home alone 30 minutes after school ends
and the and I don't know they took pity
on me and I did not actually have to
serve detention